il s'agit d'un volet particulièrement
stratégique et ce à plusieurs égards
d'une part parce que le secteur des
transports est le premier secteur
émetteur de co2 en france il est
responsable de 31 % des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre au surplus ces secteurs
fait figure de mauvais élève
d'après le haut conseil pour le climat
le secteur des transports est lé seul
secteur en france dont les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre ont augmenté depuis
les années 1990 d'autre part parce que
certaines des mesures envisagées auront
des conséquences concrètes sur la vie de
nos concitoyens et sur leur liberté de
se déplacer
je pense par exemple l'article 27 qui
prévoit la mise en place de nouvelles
zones à faibles émissions dans les
agglomérations de plus de cent cinquante
mille habitants et des restrictions de
circulation importantes dans les airs et
des feux créée par l'homme ce qui aura
pour conséquence une réorganisation de
nos mobilité en zone urbaine où j'en
profite pour souligner qu'au-delà du
transport de voyageurs ce projet de loi
prévoit aussi des mesures relatives au
transport de marchandises transports qui
a souvent été un angle mort des
politiques de mobilité
les rapporteurs de la mission
d'information relative au transport de
marchandises face aux impératifs
environnementaux qui doit rendre ses
conclusions la semaine prochaine
souhaiteront sans doute vous interrogé à
ce sujet avant de vous céder la parole
je souhaite vous interroger sur trois
points du texte d'abord je souhaiterais
vous entendre sur l'articulation entre
le projet de loi les différentes
missions ou réflexions en cours sur les
transports je pense par exemple aux
travaux sur la stratégie pour le
développement du fret ferroviaire sur la
transition énergétique du transport
routier ou encore à la mission relative
à la logistique urbaine durable
il me semble que ces travaux sont en
lien avec direct avec certaines des
dispositions envisagées par le texte
dès lors est il envisagé d'en remettre
les conclusions sous peu afin de nourrir
l'examen du projet de loi du sénat
ensuite pourriez vous revenir sur la
portée concrète des mesures
programmatiques inscrits dans le titre
se déplacer du texte je pense notamment
à l'article 35 relative aux prix du
carbone sur le transport aérien
et dont on se demande au vu de sa
rédaction et de nombreuses conditions
posées dans quelle mesure il sera
réellement applicable
enfin et cela monsieur le ministre vous
êtes un drap sans doute pas pourriez
vous nous donner des détails sur ce
dispositif prévu à l'article 32 qui je
dois vous la vie monsieur le ministre
nous laisse un peu sur notre faim
il est question d'une contribution
régionale sur le transport de
marchandises qui serait basée sur une
expérimentation du transfert des routes
aux régions nous ne connaissons pas bien
entendu les tenants et les aboutissants
ment à ce stade pour une simple raison
que cette expérimentation relève d'un
autre texte
le projet de loi 4d qui n'a pas encore
été déposé
l'article fait par ailleurs référence à
des contributions régionales mais aussi
départemental en cas de report de trafic
pourriez vous nous aider à y voir plus
clair sur dispositifs envisagés
monsieur mini jeux vous êtes désormais
la parole afin de avant de donner la
parole à philippe tabarot qui est
rapporteur au titre de la loi climat sur
le titre se déplacer monsieur le
ministre je vous sais d'appareils mais
les sénateurs essayé d'être un succès
pour laisser un peu de place au débat et
peut-être d'abord faire un court propos
de deux cas l'agent de répondre le plus
exactement possible à vos questions ont
d'abord vous dire que l'examen de ce
projet de loi s'inscrit dans la
continuité de la politique du
gouvernement
vous avez cité la part que prend le
transport dans les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre et nous avons très
largement d'abord soutenu le
développement du mode ferroviaire dont
on sait que par structure par
construction il est plus écologique et
que les autres modes crois que le plan
de relance traduit bien nos ambitions
c'était 11 milliards sur les 100
milliards du plan du gouvernement dont 5
milliards
peu ou prou pour pour le mode
ferroviaire nous avons au global sans
revenir sur l'ensemble de l'action menée
depuis 2007 déjà engrangé quelques
résultats
je prends comme exemple la part des
véhicules électriques x 4 en un an le
nombre de pistes cyclables sécurisées +
30 % en quatre ans ou encore
l'investissement au sens large dans les
infrastructures de transport
+ 50% depuis depuis quatre ans donc
cette politique de moyens avec des
premiers résultats
peut-être un mot sur le contexte qui est
un contexte particulier puisque nous
vivons dans le champ des transports et
notamment du transport particulier est
élu transports communs au sens large à
la fois la crise économique la plus
grave la plus profonde et en même temps
si je peux dire la plus grande
transformation technologique que ce
secteur n'a pas connu depuis peut-être
maintenant que de 50 ans je pense
notamment à l'électrification des
véhicules particuliers et donc la
mauvaise façon de répondre c'est de
répondre qu'à la crise sans investir
massivement sur la transformation
technologique et l'autre façon de
répondre c'est effectivement ne pas
suffisamment amortir la crise avec le dk
sociale les dégâts sociaux que cela
pourrait pourrait engager
nous avons reçu les propositions de la
commission 42 mesure sur le titre iii
nous avons d'ores et déjà traduit 27
mesure soit sous l'angle du plan de
relance soit dans les projets de loi de
financement rectificatif ou initiaux ou
encore certain nombre de mesures par ce
texte ou de façon réglementaire
peut-être vous dire quelques mots sur
les principaux enjeux avant de répondre
à votre question
le principal enjeu parce que c'est le
gros des émissions c'est évidemment la
transition des véhicules particuliers
je regardais quelques chiffres il ya
quelques jours mais on annonce d'abord
que la transition va être beaucoup plus
rapide que prévu et la plupart des
prévisionnistes disent maintenant qu'en
2030 nous aurons 50 % des véhicules
vendus au niveau mondial qui seront des
véhicules électriques à batterie
c'est évidemment beaucoup moins dans les
projections d'il ya trois ans mais je le
dis je le dis à nouveau ici cette
transition m extrêmement rapide il faut
que la france prenne sa part et que les
et les industriels les constructeurs
français soient soient pleinement au
rendez vous pour ce faire nous avons est
un diamant accélérer notre politique de
déploiement des bornes de recharge un
mot nous avons aujourd'hui 540 mille
bornes de recharge installée chez les
particuliers et dans les entreprises
nous avons 90 % des recharges et nous
avons vous savez ce plan de 200 mille
bornes d'ici 2022 à la fois sur les
grands axes routiers et autoroutiers de
manière à faire ce qu'on appelle
l'itinérance est à dire donner confiance
à l'utilisateur le soutien en vélo je
savais en a peut-être au gré des
questions mais c'est évidemment un sujet
très comment dire l'âge c'est important
pour nous pardon et peut-être simplement
pour finir sur votre question d'abord
dire que sur le fret ferroviaire nous
avons une stratégie nationale qui sera
présenté au parlement dans les prochains
mois nous avons eu l'occasion d'en
débattre ici mais d'ores et déjà des
actes ont été posés puisque pendant le
coeur de la crise nous avons à la fois
soutenu les différents opérateurs nous
avons baissé les péages nous
investissons massivement dans les
infrastructures portuaires et
ferroviaires de manière à mieux
connecter ce mode au mode ou au mode
maritime au sens large
je suis la logistique urbaine de la même
façon nous investissements investissons
massivement sur sur les ports de manière
à en faire des vrais zone industrialo
portuaire dans le contexte du breakbeat
où vous savez que nos amis et néanmoins
concurrents parfois anglais ont des
plans extrêmement dynamique et enfin sur
l'aérien
avant de répondre à votre question sur
le l'éco-contribution routière sur
l'arrière je pense que là aussi nous
sommes dans un moment de réflexion tout
à fait particulier parce que d'abord la
transformation technologique est tout à
fait importante que du fait de
l'industrie aéronautique française qui
est européenne qui a qui est d'envergure
mondiale nous sommes en capacité là
d'influer d'influer très concrètement
cette transformation écologique et
industriels et je pense qu'il y aura des
réflexions à mener au niveau
international je dirais peut-être un mot
tout à l'heure de manière à beaucoup
mieux intégrer la dimension
environnementale enfin pour préciser
peut-être ce qui a été présenté en
conseil des ministres ce matin le projet
de loi 4d prévoit effectivement une
expérimentation de transfert des routes
aux régions c'est une expérimentation
qui se fait sur la base du volontariat
pour cinq ans avec une liste des routes
qui transférables qui sera publiée par
décret sous deux mois post adoption du
projet de loi cadre des en question et
je pourrai revenir si vous voulez ou
créent des questions avec davantage de
précision voilà monsieur le président au
préalable quelques mots de de cavage
prévient merci monsieur
le ministre ces propos on craque je vais
donner la parole aux rapporteurs
philippe tabarot et puis après aux deux
rapporteurs de la mission
madame bonne foi et monsieur point trop
je présidais remercie monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur cinq
que pour un monsieur le ministre
le texte prévoit plusieurs dispositions
sur la décarbonation de transport
routier de voyageurs et de marchandises
peu de dispositions concernent le
développement des modes ferroviaire et
fluvial on vient d'en parler alors que
même nous percevons une importante
volonté des acteurs d'avancé sur ces
sujets en témoigne la démarche de 4 f
sur le fret ferroviaire le travail en
cours sur la définition d'une stratégie
pour le développement du fret
ferroviaire ou encore la signature du
contrat de performance entre vnf et
l'état pourquoi avoir fait ce choix
alors que vous en parlait régulièrement
alors gelé répétaient également je crois
monsieur papinutti alors de nos
auditions
je reconnais tout ce que votre
gouvernement faire la matière ou
prévoient de faire en la matière et
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir inscrit dans la
loi notamment au niveau des objectifs
seriez vous favorable à la joute
disposition sur ces sujets et et kong
rave dans le marbre de la loi les
objectifs notamment de multiplier par
deux la part du fret ferroviaire et du
flux fret fluvial dans dans notre report
modal en france deuxième point
une question qui a déjà été abordé par
notre président je voudrais appuyer ses
propos sur l'écotaxe non pardon l'éco
contribution
nous avons eu connaissance du projet
d'ordonnancé enfin hier matin cher
jacques fernique de du projet
d'ordonnancé pour les collectivités la
collectivité européenne d'alsace mais
nous avons vraiment besoin d'éclairage
sur la manière dont vous envisagez le
dispositif
concrètement nous nous interrogeons par
exemple sur les risques de concurrence
inter régionale sur les éventuels
reports que pourrait causer la mise en
place d'une écotaxe e régional ou encore
sur l'articulation concrète du
dispositif entre les régions et les
départements
quels seront les possibilités en matière
d'assiette et de taux qui financera
notamment les coûts de collecte et vous
essayez de nous l'expliquer nous
comprenons un tout petit peu mieux
depuis ce matin mais nous n'avions pas
compris pourquoi vous donniez cette
possibilité aux régions avant même de
leur donner la compétence à travers la
loi cadets nous pensons que ça a été
fait à l'envers troisième fois je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur
l'articulation entre d'une part
l'article 25 qui prévoit un nouveau
jalon dans la décarbonation des
transports terrestres avant la fin de
vente des poids lourds neufs d'ici 2040
et l'article 30 qui vise à supprimer
l'avantagé fiscal sur le gasoil routier
d'ici 2030
pourquoi cette différence entre 2030 et
et pourquoi vous ne parlez pas
suffisamment de biocarburants qui à
notre avis pour être une solution
intermédiaire par rapport à ces
différentes échéances
quatrième point concernant un sujet que
vous appréciez tout particulièrement je
le sais leiria l'article 36 j'aimerais
savoir et comprendre la méthodologie
ayant conduit à retenir le seuil de 2h30
je sais que c'était pas le seuil que
souhaitait initialement la convention
citoyenne s'agit style du seuil en deçà
duquel il est généralement considéré que
l'air y est plus chronophage que le
ferroviaire considérant notamment les
temps de transport vers l'aéroport le
centre ville ou encore les contrôles de
sécurité
je note par ailleurs que le projet de
loi dispose qu'il pourra entre
guillemets
être dérogé à cette interdiction lorsque
les services aériens assure
majoritairement le transport de
passagers en correspondance
majoritairement et est important je
n'imagine par rapport à votre réflexion
quels critères précis seront retenus
pour établir que le service aérien
assurera majoritairement un transport de
passagers en correspondance suite à
l'application de cette dérogation
pouvait vous dire quelles seront les
lignes directement concernés par cette
interdiction
convenez monsieur le ministre que le
dispositif proposé n'est pas très fiable
[Applaudissements]
alternativement une dérogation
s'appliquant directement aux passagers
en correspondance plutôt qu'aux lignes
at-elle été envisagée ne
permettrait-elle pas d'atteindre plus
directement l'objectif fixé par
l'article 36 à savoir limiter les
émissions des vols intérieurs pour des
trajets intérieurs pouvant se faire en
moins de temps en train sans pour autant
empêcher nos concitoyens de recourir à
l'aérien pour prendre une correspondance
enfin l'article 38 sur l'aérien
quand olivier jacquin ou un terminé de
commenter les actions chez 1re livier
monsieur le ministre
l'article 38 on voit apparaître pour la
première fois en droit français la
notion de compensation carbone
je rappelle que pour être efficace une
compensation carbone doit remplir quatre
critères cumulatifs la mesurabilité les
émissions évitées doivent être
comptabilisés sur la base d'une
méthodologie certifier la vérifiabilité
la permanence les émissions doivent être
évitée pendant un certain nombre
d'années
enfin l'additionnalité les émissions
n'aurait pas réduite en l'absence du
projet des doutes sont régulièrement
émis quant à l'efficacité des mécanismes
de compensation
au regard de ces critères une étude de
2016 duo qu institue un institut
allemand
comme son nom l indique pas de recherche
sur l'environnement estime que sur 5600
projet publié 85 d'entre eux avaient une
faible probabilité d'assurer les
réductions d'émissions promise et
l'additionnalité du projet ne
faudrait-il pas
à tout le moins profité du projet de loi
pour définir pour la première fois en
droit français la notion de compensation
de carbone et inscrire dans le droit la
nécessité de remplir ces quatre critères
cumulatifs
d'une manière générale monsieur le
ministre ne pensez-vous pas avoir à
travers ce projet de loi stigmatiser le
transport aérien que vous connaissez
pourtant très bien et qui notamment ce
moment ne mérite pas ces procès
d'intention enfin le seul ministre comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à la
ministre pompili la semaine dernière je
m'inquiète des nombreuses mesures de
taxation et d'interdictions proposées
dans ce titre
dans le contexte que nous connaissons je
crois que l'acceptabilité de nos
concitoyens mise à rude épreuve ces
dernières années j'ai peur qu'elle ne
soit pas au rendez vous la volonté de
contenter tout le monde
ce en même temps écologique ne va-t-il
pas montré ses limites à travers ce
projet de loi climat merci madame votre
foi au titre des missions information
tant merci monsieur le président bonjour
monsieur le ministre la mission
d'information donc sur les impacts
environnementaux du transport de
marchandises va rendre son rapport la
semaine prochaine comme ça a été dit
vous en serez bien évidemment
destinateur nous avons beaucoup
travaillé avec mon collègue rémy
pointereau la décarbonation du secteur
est bien sûr une question essentielle
mais les gaz à effet de serre ne sont
pas la seule externalités négatives
causées par le transport routier en
particulier pour le transport routier en
particulier en effet et nous l'avons
nous les avons entendus nombre d'élus et
de citoyens sont de plus en plus
préoccupés par d'autres nuisances
importantes générées par le transport
des marchandises des poids lourds
notamment ceux en transit et notamment
lorsque ces poids lourds empruntent le
réseau secondaire au lieu d'emprunter
les autoroutes pour économiser quelques
euros
je voulais déjà dit
illustre encore une fois mon propos pour
ce qui se passe dans mon département
mais ça se passe également ailleurs donc
sur la route nationale 10 au lieu de
prendre l'autoroute pour économiser
quelques euros on prend l'autoroute
gratuite c'est à dire la route nationale
10 conséquence insécurité routière
dégradation de la chaussée nuisances
sonores émissions de particules métaux
lourds dans les sols déchets et cetera
cette situation de quitter l'autoroute
pour par la nationale c'est ce qu'on
appelle les fuites et donc nombre d'élus
souhaiterait pouvoir prendre des arrêtés
restreignant la circulation sur donc
cette partie
c'est ce qu'on appelle donc ses fuites
sur ces secteurs de voirie mais les
démarches semblent extrêmement combler
complexe donc ma première question vous
ne pensez vous pas que nous pourrions
envisager un dispositif qui serait
similaire à celui des zones à faibles
émissions
zone affaires émission qui concerne les
agglomérations les métropoles les villes
uniquement donc un dispositif similaire
mais qui concernerait d'autres parties
du territoire y compris les partis plus
rurales et donc qu'il s'appuierait sur
les externalités négatives du transport
routier
c'est à dire au delà des problématiques
de pollution de l'air et donc qui
permettrait aux élus locaux de pouvoir
prendre des arrêtés donc de restrictions
de circulation et donc de mieux réguler
cette circulation en attendant peut-être
qu'un jour bien évidemment et c'est
notre voeu les marchandises puissent
aller sur le rail par exemple
aujourd'hui la seule réponse qui a porté
ses des mesures de restriction de
circulation qui sont prises par les
préfets à savoir limitations de vitesse
interdiction de doubler et cetera
mais ce sont des mesures qui ne sont
absolument pas respectée c'est le cas
chez illustre pour un mon département
900 pv à l'année pour 10000 poids lourds
jours donc on voit bien l'état de la
situation
le sait il ya un mois à peine une
personne est décédée une automobiliste
en ayant comment dire en rentrant dans
un poids lourd stationné sur une bande
d'arrêt d'urgence donc un stationnement
interdit et le poids lourds a pu
repartir en s'acquittant de l'amendé
alors qu'il y avait un mort et
aujourd'hui encore les poids lourds sont
stationnés au même endroit sachant bien
évidemment que lorsqu'ils quittent ce
stationnement c'est un poids mort qui
quitte la nationale alors que les
véhicules arrivent à plus de 110 km
heure dont vous imaginez l'impact
possible donc on voit bien que les
mesures de restrictions qui sont
aujourd'hui mises en place par les
préfets ne suffisent pas donc est ce que
vous ne pensez pas qu'il faille
renforcer ses mesures de restrictions
tant pour les préfets que de contrôle
avec une même si les contrôles ont été
renforcés avec des amendes qu'ils soient
des amendes plus beaucoup plus forte
dont beaucoup plus dissuasive
en résumé puisque il me semble que ce
n'est pas possible d'obliger les poids
lourds et ceux en transit à particuliers
en particulier en prend les autoroutes
on pourrait au moins tout faire pour
essayer de les dissuader de prendre les
voies secondaires donc les nationales et
départementales en renforçant et en
facilitant l'arsenal des restrictions
qui pourraient être mises en place par
les élus haut par les préfets et donc ma
question porte sur ces sujets qu'ils
soient extrêmement prégnante temps pour
les élus que pour les
riverain merci pour votre pension mais
aussi pour l'environnement
la parole est à rémy cointreau
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre
donc la mission que nous menons avec ma
collègue nicole bonnefoy a permis de
mettre en lumière également le fort
potentiel des modes massifiés en matière
de réduction des mythes des émissions
carbone mais également de polluants
atmosphériques et nuisances
il faut ne faut pas bien sûr opposé les
modes et il est clair que renforcer la
compétitivité du fer et du fluvial qui
ne représente je vous rappelle qu'à
peine 15% voire 14 % du fret de
marchandises
et bien c'est un levier puissant de
transition écologique
votre gouvernement a engagé un certain
nombre de chantiers sur le sujet
ferroviaire en particulier avec
notamment des investissements dans le
réseau ferré cependant les travaux de la
mission est notamment l'audition des
représentants de des opérateurs
céréales notamment accès axéréal une
hausse coopérative française une des
premières ont illustré que la qualité de
l'infrastructure n'était pas le seul
obstacle au développement du rail de
nombreuses entreprises engagées dans le
fret ferroviaire ont indiqué que la
procédure très rigide tribution des
sillons le risque d'annulations et de
retards
avec des pénalités très importante de la
part de sncf réseau vis-à-vis des
entreprises
et puis la complexité des relations avec
les cncf réseau constituer des freins
très important report modal alors que
nos pratiques de consommation évoluent
et demande toujours davantage dit ma
diète d'immédiateté le ferroviaire va
devenir un mode à la fois flexible et
réactif s'il veut rester pertinent et
concurrencer la route
il paraît donc évident que sncf réseau
doit réformer son mode de fonctionnement
est-ce qu'elle en a la volonté je
l'espère et que le retour offert ne soit
pas vu comme ils contrainte parce que le
dans toutes les auditions on a pu
constater que de nombreuses entreprises
ne croyez plus report modal du fait de
la difficulté de pouvoir mettre en
fonction des trains de marchandises
alors monsieur le ministre quel son
vos orientations pour renforcer la
souplesse et la qualité service du rail
afin que ce mode puisse enfin
correspondre aux vrais besoins des
entreprises je me fais prendre trois
points dont le panier déjà chargé mais
je vais essayer de faire ça en bonne
entente et pour commencer par les propos
de monsieur le rapporteur sur le vecteur
est le mode ferroviaire et fluvial je ne
reviens pas sur les investissements nous
avons consenti vous les connaissez
maintenant bien bon par nature je suis
toujours favorable au débat politique et
parlementaire donc nous étudierons et
nous vous répondrons au moment requis
sur ces différents sujets vous
connaissez parfaitement les contres un
des articles 40 45
mais voilà là dessus ouverture pour
avoir c'était discussions sur les sujets
de l'éco contribution de poids lourds
peut-être que le plus simple c'est de
vous donner l'exemple de celle qui
serait mise en place pour la communauté
européenne d'alsace pour il ya d'abord
que le gouvernement l'a fait à la
demande de plusieurs régions notamment
grand test et l'île de france
l'objectif c'est de donner la
possibilité aux régions d'instituer une
contribution assise sur le transport
routier de marchandises la nature de
cette contribution ne sera pas
préalablement définies dans la loi les
collectivités sont libres de faire le
choix nous redevances par exemple ou
d'une taxe est par ailleurs certains
départements ou les départements
pourront demander à l'appliquer sur
certaines routes départementales pour
éviter les reports de trafic dont vous
avez les uns et les autres fait mention
par exemple ordonnance
ces lois donc la collectivité européenne
d'alsace le contenu de cette de cette
expérimentation c'est bien une taxe et
non redevance pour services rendus
le redoutable et le propriétaire du
véhicule et un équipement électronique
embarqué sera obligatoire pour les
véhicules à 6 juillet la taxe pose la
question du laon qu'à sa réponse pour
partie au sujet du contrôle et
éventuellement de la sanction et
plusieurs marges de manoeuvre sont à la
main de la collectivité en question
notamment l'exemption des véhicules le
réseau précise taxable ou encore les
pôles kilométrique et les modulations
voilà par l'exemple ce que pourrait
préfigurer d'autres expérimentations
dont j'ai rappelé le cadre dans vos
précédentes sur les biocarburants dits
atteint près de préciser le la
philosophie le gouvernement sur le sujet
d'abord les biocarburants dont nous
parlons sont en quantité limitée donc
l'objectif c'est de les prioriser sur
les mobilités les plus lourdes qui par
nature sont celles qui sont les plus
difficiles électrifié donc c'est ce que
nous faisons sur le troisième sujet que
vous avez évoquées qui était le sujet
rien ne pas oublier le volet tulle et le
sujet et 2h30 dire d'abord que le
secteur aérien a résisté
il a résisté notamment pour l'industrie
aéronautique et vous voyez aujourd'hui
airbus a annoncé la mise en place d'une
chaîne d'assemblage de l'airbus a321 à
toulouse et le grand risque était
effectivement pour l'industrie
aéronautique de gripper la machine
notamment sur l'implantation française
étant les grands groupes donneurs
d'ordre les pme ont bien résisté et
aujourd'hui le trafic aérien est très
largement reparti en asie en chine il
est à 110 % de son niveau de 2009 en
amérique du nord autour de 80% la
l'europe aujourd'hui koné awa dembaya
plus un peu plus poussif de l'ordre de
40% des choses vont aller en
s'améliorant sur des critères objectifs
pour définir dès 10h30 d'abord d'y
passer lés critères de temps de
transport pour un point sur les
exceptions qui peuvent être faits
déception porte notamment sur les taux
de correspondance donc majorité égal à
50% et nous avons voulu préserver
évidemment les leob notamment l'offre de
croatie charles de gaulle mais je
rappelle aussi qu orly et arnott les
vols les vols outre-mer tout ça se fait
évidemment dont la consultation avec les
avec les élus l'objectif que nous
faisons avec cette règle dès 2h30 c'est
d'abord nous assurer de la connectivité
des territoires du cul des enclaves en
savait que le gouvernement a une
politique sur les lignes d'aménagement
du territoire pour permettre ou
maintenir l'attractivité des territoires
j'ai souvent pris le grand massif
central comme comme exemple mais je
crois que cela illustre bien il serait
bien le propos par ailleurs et vous le
savez quand une ligne à grande vitesse
est mise en oeuvre est la sèche un peu
mais tu es mécaniquement le trafic
aérien
on l'a vu sur paris-strasbourg on l'a vu
sur bordeaux paris on l'a vu sur avignon
assez mécaniquement et en quelques mois
l'aérien en tout cas les clients de
l'aérien se reportent sur le tgv
notamment pour les trajets point besoin
et puis d'une manière générale sur le
soutien du transport aérien à la fois
les exploitants aéroportuaire les
compagnies aériennes et l'industrie
aéronautique
c'est un peu ce que je disais dans mon
propos liminaire c'est que la
transformation elle et elle est très
rapide
elle va demander de s'organiser par
phases d'abord effectivement massifier
la production de biocarburants de
deuxième génération
évidemment nous préparer à la transition
technologique c'est le milliard et demi
qui a été investi sur deux ans notamment
pour préparer l'hybridation et le saut
technologique vers l'avion à hydrogène
et je dois dire que quand je vois les
projets qui sont présentés à la fois en
france en europe et de par le monde les
choses avancent là aussi beaucoup plus
vite que prévu et puis dans cette phase
de transition dans lesquels nous ne
disposons pas encore des de la rupture
technologique la compensation est un
élément intéressant évidemment elle
sujet du prix de la compensation
la qualité les projets présentés les
sujets de la territorialisation des
projets évident que c'est plus
intéressant de ne point de vue de
financer des projets de compensation qui
sont français territorialisée et à des
coûts qui sont qui sont abordables pour
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
je regarde si vous aviez posé la
question effectivement des lignes
concernées pour préciser que les lignes
concernées en l'état sont les lignes
orly bordeaux orly nantes et orly lyon
et vous savez que le sujet c'est qu'est
le sujet connexe évidemment la
restructuration du groupe la france qui
se produit en même temps qui avait
d'ailleurs débuté avant la crise et donc
nous aurons un certain nombre de lignes
qui soit vont être transféré à sa
filiale transavia soit pour être reprise
par d'autres opérateurs mais j'avais
déjà prononcés le chiffre d'environ une
dizaine de lignes au global qui ne
verront pas de reprise et donc la
connectivité aérienne au moins dans ce
premier temps et à mener est amené à
diminuer tout ça se passant dans un
moment nous avons très largement
réinvesti dans le ferroviaire pour
répondre à madame la sénatrice bonne foi
à dire peut-être que ce que j'ai essayé
d'avancer ou d'illustrés au travers de à
la fois delà du projet d'éco
contribution poids lourds et du projet
d'expérimentation d'un doigt cap des ce
sont des dispositifs qui seront à la
disposition des territoires et qu'il
n'est pas impossible d'envisager une
expérimentation sur lac ce que vous
défendez ardemment en rappelant
toutefois que beaucoup de travaux ont
été faits et que les arrêtés ne peuvent
enfin que tous les arrêtés doivent être
conformes évidemment à l'alimentation
européenne que vous connaissez fort bien
pour répondre pour finir à monsieur le
sénateur cointreau ça aussi je ne je ne
reviens pas sur tout ce que nous faisons
pour la compétitivité du fer et et du
mode fluvial
quelques chiffres quand même j'avais dit
tout à l'heure 11 milliards du plan de
relance 5 milliards pour le ferroviaire
mais des investissements considérables
sur les infrastructures portuaires on
voit bien que en général les
marchandises ne transite pas par le rail
parce que les connectivités aux grands
pôles d'échangés multimodaux notamment
les ports
son mal réalisés nous avons réinvesti
beaucoup sur l'outil portuaire la
qualité des infrastructures au sens
large vous le savez elle a été dégradé
par la vétusté que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui par le sous-investissement
chronique
nous avons un plan de régénération qui
est tout à fait important la
disponibilité des sillons c'est un sujet
complexe parce qu'on l'a été avec la
croissance du tgv là je parle du mode
sur vers la croissance du tgv
l'extension des horaires et les travaux
de rattrapage
nous savons très bien que nous avons un
réseau qui jusqu'en 2023 au moins subi
notamment la nuit beaucoup de travaux et
donc diminue la disponibilité des
sillons et donc on a cette équation à
plusieurs inconnues où on doit à la fois
rattraper très fortement le travail fait
sur le réseau lui-même soutenir les
opérateurs sur le prix parce qu'on sait
très bien que le sujet c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on vous passe et 1
contenait entre perpignan fra gce 30%
moins cher sur la route que par le rail
est donc ça fait pas ça fait partie là
aussi les dispositifs que nous avons
mises en place pour le soutien aux
opérateurs et la baisse du prix des
péages et puis évidemment nous assurer
que l'opérateur de réseau sncf réseau
rempli son office que sa tâche lui-même
subissant en tout cas mettant en oeuvre
de très grands de très grandes
transformations
donc nous essayons de mener tout ça deux
concerts mais j'avais eu l'occasion de
le dire c'est un travail énorme qui est
fait actuellement avec des améliorations
de qualité de service qui ne se verront
finalement qu'à compter de 2023 temps
les travaux sur le réseau sont
considérables voilà en quelques mots
monsieur le président c'est peut-être
que c'est joli et des points je
reviendrai au cours des prochaines
vacances monsieur chevrollier il est ou
au milieu
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre comme toute l'économie secteur
des transports face à un défi majeur de
la décarbonation vous l'avez évoqué et
sa secteur qui la filière automobile
française le secteur transport
automobile et les constructeurs
automobiles français ont ont déjà connu
les phases d'adaptation des évolutions
législatives conséquente ces dernières
années là ils doivent encore s'adapter à
des nouveaux caps que vous nous fixer
moi je voudrais avoir une question assez
ouverte à vous poser sur en direction
justement quel message pour les
constructeurs et pour les utilisateurs
des véhicules automobiles très nombreux
dans nos territoires ruraux comment vous
concevez des usages de l'automobile dans
les prochaines années un des axes forts
de votre projet loi concerne les
véhicules lourds
les poids lourds qui seront interdits à
les véhicules lourds diesel seront
interdits à la vente en 2040 donc ccd
enjeu considérable pour ce secteur des
transports est donc faut trouver la
bonne équation pour assurer la viabilité
à ces acteurs essentiels la logistique
de notre pays donc pour changer il faut
avoir une organisation planification
avec un calendrier qui qui soit réaliste
quand est ce que précisément on pouvait
garantir à ces acteurs économiques les
motorisations propres seront disponibles
en masse pour l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques comment accompagner ces
entreprises y aller il ya les grandes
entreprises françaises de transport mais
aussi beaucoup d'entreprises les pme et
entreprises de taille intermédiaire dans
ce secteur-là qu'il faudra accompagner
avec une planification en tout cas c'est
un souhait de de la profession je
reviens sur le point du ferroviaire vous
avez
indiqué qu' il était capital moi je
voudrais vous alerter sur les
conventions de desserte est ce que c'est
bien la promotion du ferroviaire mais
dans les territoires comme le mien laval
nous sommes à 70 minutes de paris en tgv
et il faut maintenir des dessertes de
tgv c'est capital pour l'attractivité de
nos territoires et vous savez est la
crise sanitaire a mené une baisse du
nombre de deux trains une baisse de la
fréquentation
donc on demande à ce que les les
dessertes soient maintenues telles que
ça existait avant en tout cas pas de pas
de diminution du nombre de trains ça
c'est capital et là on attend vraiment
un soutien de l'état dans ce domaine là
parce que avec la dans les négociations
avec la sncf il est vraiment un capital
de maintenir ce qu'on a aujourd'hui
et avec les références qui seront pas
les références de 2020 continue la crise
sanitaire pouvoir prendre des références
d'avant crise sanitaire voie où d'après
mais prendre le temps pour maintenir des
dessertes dans le territoire merci merci
chers collègues
la parole est à monsieur fernique merci
monsieur le président j'ai essayé d'être
rapide j'ai trois sujets sur l'article
27 les lé feu mobilité monsieur le
ministre
donc mon souci porte sur la bonne
articulation à trouver entre les
collectivités locales qui mettent et
mettrons en place le dispositif de façon
adaptée à leur territoire et l'état et
la loi qui doivent en faire assez pour
donner l'orientation et l'obligation
d'agir mais pas trop sous peine
d'empêcher les collectivités concernées
d'avoir les coudées franches pour
convaincre concertée adapté accompagner
ce qui est déterminant pour la réussite
du dispositif
là dessus je pense qu'il serait bon que
notre sénat arrive à convaincre la
sambine l'assemblée qu'il faut certes
être ferme sur les objectifs
d'amélioration de la qualité de l'air
mais qu'il serait contreproductif de
vouloir que chacun ait des feux avance
au même rythme selon un calendrier fixé
par la loi des restrictions progressive
des différentes catégories critères en
clair
l'eurométropole de strasbourg par
exemple où il a paru nécessaire que
l'ensemble des communes choix dans les
années feu ce qui n'est pas rien et qui
ambitionne notamment l'interdiction des
critères du
en 2028 et donc une dédiée et lisa sion
j'y suis arrivé conséquente serait
particulièrement contrariée dans sa
démarche si elle devait appliquer à la
lettre le calendrier voté pour l'instant
par l'assemblée sur les critères 5 2023
les quatre 24 et les trois en 2025
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions ça
serait clairement le cas si on ne
laissait pas la main à la souplesse
locales surtout si elle est ambitieuse
sur l'article 30 de la contribution
poids lourds pour les régions
volontaires là-dessus l'expérience
alsacienne m'amène à pointer 4 problème
la nécessité de ne pas traîner quand il
y à volonté politique régionale sur le
sujet là dessus il faut que l'état sache
accéléré ce qui dépend de lui
les ordonnances nécessaires ça bouge
enfin pour l'alsace on l'a vu depuis
hier matin
mais entre 2005 l'amendement bur et 2018
la loi sur la cea avouer que les camions
chassés par la taxe allemande ont eu le
temps de faire des dégâts
d'autant que votre ordonnance c'est ce
qui m'inquiète prévoit encore 6 ans
maximum de délai devant nous avant la
mise en oeuvre le deuxième problème
c'est l'effet de bord le caractère
localiser volonté à cette contribution
va susciter des transferts indésirables
de trafic
le troisième problème c'est d'assurer
des conditions précises qui rassureront
les transporteurs en assurant la
répercussion automatique du coup sûr les
chargeurs sous forme de bas de page
obligé sur les factures le quatrième
problème est votre projet d'ordonnancé
c'est d'y répondre
c'est toucher bien davantage les
transports qui pose souci les trajets
longs les trajets très émetteurs plutôt
que les petits trajets des transporteurs
locaux pour lesquels le transfert modal
est impossible autrement dit une taxe
kilométrique progressive différencié en
fonction de la classe d'émission euro
avec des exonérations possible et je
voudrais être bien sûr d'avoir compris
que la marge de 3,5 à 12 tonnes
qu'indique l'ordonance le projet dans
noces et bien la fourchette dans
laquelle la collectivité pourra choisir
le seuil de déclenchement de la taxe
donc cette taxe touchera d'évidence tous
les poids lourds au dessus de 12 tonnes
mais pas les véhicules utilisés en ut à
des jets en dessous de 3,5
enfin mon troisième sujet si j'ai pas
trop débordés c'est sûr c'est sur le
vélo
le développement récent du vélo montre
combien nos objectifs de 9% de part
modale en 2024 et 12 en 2030 sont à
notre portée pour y parvenir le
développement des infrastructures
sécurisées est essentielle certes les
financements vous l'avez dit on atteint
aujourd'hui un niveau bien meilleur par
le passé mais ne faut-il pas passer
encore un autre registre intervention
nos collectivités locales ont besoin
d'un accompagnement encore renforcée
avec un fond vélo d'une ampleur nouvelle
merci chers collègues je l'aimais d'anna
parole à monsieur gold merci monsieur le
président et ses ministres
la loi mobilité de décembre 2019 avait
fixé comme objectif ambitieux ce site
d'améliorer concrètement la mobilité au
quotidien de tous les citoyens et dans
tous les territoires grâce à des
solutions de transport plus efficace
plus propre plus accessible le projet
doit climat réitère cette intention en
dispose en son article 25 bis que l'état
se fixe pour objectif d'accompagner les
ménages dans le report modal vers les
modes de transport les moins polluants
par une action ciblée en priorité des
zones à faibles émissions mobilité cet
objectif est couplé à celui de la fin de
la vente des véhicules particulières
neuves émettant plus de 123 grammes de
dioxyde de carbone par kilomètre privé
l'article 25 apportés à tous et partout
des solutions alternatives à la
dépendance lusage individus voiture
individuelle est un véritable défi
particulièrement en zone rurale où la
voiture individuelle est bien souvent le
seul moyen pour se déplacer au quotidien
dans ce sens la loi a offert la
possibilité aux intercommunalités de
devenir autour autorités organisatrices
des mobilités en prenant la compétence
et plus de 900 communautés sont
concernés et devait donc décidée avant
le 31 mars 2021 alors au delà de la loi
climat
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner déjà
un bilan du nombre de pci qui ont choisi
de se doter de la compétence mobilité
ces alternatives peut être envisagée
dans les opci les plus peuplées
notamment les métropoles les communautés
d'agglo les territoires les moins
peuplées e où la voiture a dit
visuel reste souvent évidemment le seul
moyen de locomotion ce territoire là
sont plus compliqué à appréhender
au delà du verdissement de la flotte des
voitures individuelles
à quelle échéance peut-on espérer une
offre de transport plus importante et
plus durable dans les zones les moins
desservis aujourd'hui et sous quelles
formes innovantes sachant que la loi
climat n'apparaît pas comme un outil au
service des transports n'apparaît pas
vraiment en tous les cas comme un outil
au service des transports en milieu
rural
merci je vais donner la parole à
monsieur blanc et après je proposerai au
ministre de répondre à quelques
collègues avant de donner la parole aux
quatre autres collègues merci merci
monsieur présent une question très très
brève quand on examine ce texte et il
n'y a qu'un seul article c'est l'article
14 qui fait référence à la recherche
on sait pourtant que sur la mobilité
c'est à travers la recherche dans la
portera des réponses importantes pour
pour la décarbonation et
de la mobilité le texte cet article 14
mentionne clé il y aura une meilleure
articulation des objectifs de la
stratégie nationale bas carbone dans la
définition des priorités stratégiques
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas monsieur
le ministre que ce texte pourrait être
une belle occasion de préciser cette
stratégie notamment dans trois domaines
qui sont essentiels le domaine de
l'hydrogène le domaine des batteries et
le domaine des véhicules hybrides on
sait qu'aujourd'hui à un frein à la
commercialisation des véhicules hybrides
c'est le peu de kilomètres autonome avec
les batteries électriques
monsieur le ministre si vous voulez bien
répondre à mes collègues l'un de vos
sujets ainsi monsieur le président pour
commencer avec monsieur le sénateur
chevrolet qui rejoint peut-être
d'ailleurs pour partie la question de
monsieur le sénateur blanc la vision du
gouvernement sur le transport automobile
elle et elle et elle et elle est
doublement d'abord je le disais c'est
une très grande transformation
technologique que nous voyons qui a
commencé d'ailleurs pour partie outre
atlantique qui se s'est accélérée et
côté allemand suite au scandale du
diesel gates est aujourd'hui on voit
bien que l'ensemble des constructeurs
mondiaux se tourner vers l'électrique
avec une très grande
une très grande dynamique ça consiste
pour les constructeurs d'abord à se
doter de l'offre je pense notamment aux
constructeurs français européens qui
bien souvent vous le savez ont une
dimension internationale
ça consiste pour l'état auprès des
acteurs privés des collectivités
d'investir dans les infrastructures de
recharge
je le disais tout à l'heure 540 mille
bornes dans les entreprises chez les
particuliers et les 100000 bornes qui
doivent vous assurez l'itinérance et
puis ça suppose d'être au rendez-vous du
soutien aux prix mais monsieur
d'ailleurs sur les camions et les
véhicules industriels on voit bien que
le sujet c'est de savoir combien et pour
combien de temps on arrive à accélérer
en tout cas amorcé et comment on arrive
à accélérer la maturité de ses
différents marchés en très grandes
transformations sur les véhicules
utilitaires légers et les camions
industriels la logique est la même sur
l'aspect construction les français
seront plus particulièrement bien
positionnée sur sur les bulles avec on
prend l'exemple du kangoo et du master
des parts de marché national tout à fait
importante et sur l'aspect régulation
l'objectif c'est bien évidemment et vous
l'avez dit d'utiliser d'user de la
souplesse maximale vous avez parlé de
l'exemple de strasbourg qui vient de
repousser d'un an le passage aux
sanctions pour poursuivre la phase
pédagogique notamment s'agissant des
delorge a des cheveux cela est
évidemment cette phase de pédagogie tout
à fait nécessaire et sur l'aspect
souplesse vis-à-vis des véhicules
utilitaires légers
c'est une attention que nous avons
précisant que le calendrier de sorties
devinette critère auquel vous avez fait
référence ne référencent pardon ne
concerne pas les vues de l'adaptation se
fera agglo par agglo comme elle le
souhaite en fonction du contexte
un contexte local sur la deuxième
sur cette dernière question pardon
s'agissant du ferroviaire et des
conventions de desserte dire je sais pas
si j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire devant
votre assemblée mais que la sncf a
prolongé pour 2022 les conventions
actuelles et que nous commençons à
discuter pour 2023
en tout cas que snc va commencer à
discuter pour les conventions 2023 de
l'est certes dans les prochaines
semaines et que l'état évidemment le les
suivra ces conventions avec toute
l'attention requise pour répondre à
monsieur le sénateur philippe ces
différentes questions je commence
peut-être par la fin sur le vélo le vélo
qui est un des grands succès de
finalement des crises successives avec
une très grande augmentation de la part
de ces pratiques ans avait commencé au
moment des grèves les grandes grèves des
transports et ça s'est poursuivi très
largement pendant sept toutes les phases
d'ailleurs 2
confinement et déconfinement que nous
avons vécu nous avons au total quasiment
paquet financier d'un milliard d'euros
quand on cumule ce que font les
collectivités et l'état et la dimension
européenne vous sautez souvenez pardon
que nous avons créé un fonds haddock en
2018 doté de 350 millions d'euros
en sept ans nous avons trois appels à
projets qui sont déjà engagés avec 323
territoires bénéficiaires et je le
disais tout à l'heure
plus de 30% des pistes cyclables
sécurisées depuis 2007 soit 10000 km le
coup de pouce vélo est évidemment un
succès ça lui permet d'ailleurs de créer
aussi une nouvelle filière de réinsérer
beaucoup de personnes hors emploi et
notamment des publics difficiles ou
sorties depuis très longtemps de
l'emploi donc c'est tout à fait
bénéfique sur le plan social et en
cumulé si on prend simplement laitages
nationale cela représente 400 millions
d'investissements entre 2018 et 2020
accessible à tout à toutes les
collectivités sur le sujet de l'
ordonnance sur deûle à séoul avait dit
elle est prévue au 1er juin ce sur le
cas pour une mise en place au 1er
janvier 2000 24 et vous me posiez la
question des différents paramètres
notamment du paramètre de la masse ou du
poids total en charge
cela fait part et cela fait parti
perdant des paramètres à discuter au
niveau local comme l'ensemble ou certain
nombre de paramètres que j'ai pu évoquer
à l'occasion de la question de monsieur
le sénateur tabarot sur les questions de
monsieur le sénateur gold peut-être dire
vous préciser que hal date nous avons
50% des dés comme comme des
collectivités des opci au niveau
national qui ont demandé la prise de
compétence donc un grand pas qui a été
franchi dans certaines régions je pense
notamment aux régions normandie grand
test et pays de la loire c'est plus de
90% des com com qui ont pris cette
compétence et en bourgogne franche comté
un peu plus 75%
la mission maintenant c'est évidemment
de l'accompagner pour que les choses
soient réellement efficace le
déploiement des nouveaux services de
mobilité
je pense totalement
aux lignes bhns est ce que vous
connaissez que one cv au garage
solidaire en passant par le transport à
la demande et vous connaissez l'ensemble
des appels à projets qui permettent ce
faisant de disposer de moyens pour le
faire je pense notamment au 4ème appel à
projets les transports en commun en site
propre et peut-être pour finir répondre
à la question de monsieur blanc qui
n'est pas tout à fait des courriers de
ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure sur sur
le sujet de la très grande
transformation technologique que nous
vivons et pour lesquels les français
doivent évidemment répondre présent la
vision du gouvernement c'est que sur le
véhicule léger nous avons
l'électrification qui va qui va ce qui
va s'imposer qui s'impose déjà beaucoup
que l'hydrogène va plutôt intéressé les
mobilités les plus lourdes les trains
les bus l'écart peut-être demain à
hydrogène mais à le souhaiter cno
logique était un peu plus lointain et
vous avez raison de pointer certaines
limites ou en tout cas certaines
conditions pour la réussite des moteurs
hybrides mais pour moi le sujet c'est un
sujet de recherche de recherche
appliquée c'est un sujet de stratégie
aussi nous voyons bien les ceux qui
réussissent aujourd'hui dans
l'électrique noms sont non seulement eu
l'intuition de poursuivre une politique
de développement très dynamique de leur
offre
pur électrique mais ils ont aussi très
largement investi dans ce qu'on appelle
la supériorité technologique
la détention de la propriété
intellectuelle sur la tarte aux graphie
sur la navigation sur les censeurs sur
les algorithmes d'intelligence
artificielle bref parce que ce qui fera
la valeur ajoutée dans l'automobile de
demain et c'est donc là aussi en dehors
des sujets de recherche stricto sensu
que les acteurs français qui je les dix
ont une dimension souvent européenne et
mondiale
pas aussi très largement investir de
manière à être dans cette course de la
supériorité technologique et commerciale
et donc de leur capacité à trouver leur
clientèle
voilà monsieur le président en quelques
mots merci monsieur le ministre
madame fille
si monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je voulais revenir sur un sujet
déjà évoquée par nos excellents
rapporteur la caisse l'absence du
fluvial dans le projet de loi climat en
effet le président de la république
avait dit qu'il reprendrait sans filtre
les propositions de cette convention
citoyenne
or pour reprendre pour reprendre les
propos de la convention citoyenne je
vais la cité elle dit notre ambition est
de redonner une place plus grande aux
trains au fluvial et aux maritimes dans
le transport de marchandises car 19 %
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sont liées au transport dont les poids
lourds dont les oeufs et les poids
lourds en sont l'origine notre intention
est de réduire significativement la part
des poids lourds dans le transport de
marchandises globale en offrant des
solutions pour mieux combiner les
différents modes de transport de
marchandises plus de trains plus de
fluviale ou de maritime
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il y a vraiment
une occasion manquée alors que nous
avons le réseau aux flux vient dé réseau
fluvial les plus importants d'europe
qu'il va y avoir la construction du
canal seine nord
ne pensez-vous pas qu'il y a un travail
significatif à faire en faveur du
fluvial en dehors des investissements
que vous avez évoqué et qui sont
significatifs je pense par exemple à la
politique fiscale la politique fiscale
française favorise encore les modes de
transport les plus émetteurs de gaz à
effet de serre et de polluants de l'air
cette politique ne favorise pas et c'est
le moins que l'on puisse dire leur pain
vers des modes de transport moins
polluants et je voulais vous poser la
question de savoir si le projet de loi
de finances
2 allait prévoir une modification de la
fiscalité pour favoriser le fluvial et
surtout pour supprimer le dégrèvement
supplémentaires sur le gazole accordée
au transport routier de marchandises
afin de le mettre progressivement au
même niveau de fiscalité que les
automobilistes particuliers
merci monsieur le ministre merci je vais
donner la parole à monsieur mandela
merci président sur le ministre je
voulais tout d'abord cela est évoqué par
ses deux collègues et vous l'avez fait
ou même dire qu'effectivement de gros
efforts ont été réalisés sur à la fois
même si ça peut nous paraître
insuffisant encore sur le fluvial le
maritime et ferroviaire et cela a été
permis je tiens à le dire parce que nous
avons dans le cadre de la l'homme
sanctuary zeller recettes de la fuite en
réaffectant une partie de la tei cpe
poids lourds et des particuliers qui
avait été un engagement pris au moment
de l'abandon de l'écotaxe en échange
avec en nombre cette écotaxe à l'époque
les professionnels s'étaient engagés à
financer au travers d'un d'une tcp
supplémentaire de 4 et 2 centimes
respectivement les les coûts
d'infrastructure donc ma question elle
est lié
cette fiscalité d'ailleurs martin
filiale de l'évoquer mais moi j'irai
encore un peu plus loin
est ce que la baisse ou l'exonération la
suppression de l'exonération de taille
c'est peu pour les professionnels
pourraient être affectés en partie ça
reste à définir entre autres à lafitte
et éventuellement à l'ademe également
pour financer la transition
parce que cette suppression de
l'exonération de fait si on affecte pas
entre guillemets elle ira comme toujours
dans le tonneau des danaïdes du budget
de l'état et ne contribuera pas à la
transition écologique et je prolonge la
question puisque c'est du même ordre sur
et je rejoins en cela les propos du
président et du rapporteur un excellent
rapporteur philippe tabarot et il m'a
dit la semaine dernière que j'avais est
excellente donc je lui renvoie la
politesse sommes très sont très bien
aiguille éduqué dans cette famille sur
la fameuse taxe redevance contribution
on l'appelle comme on veut
au niveau régional moi je souligne le
manque de cohérence également avec un
texte 4d qui nous arrive dans lequel on
va retrouver encore un volet donc
mobilité transports transférer la
compétence éventuellement même pour une
expérimentons expérimentation de cinq
ans en région voire aux départements par
convention et vous avez cité l'exemple
de la cause de la communauté d'alsace et
vous avez évoqué un appareil embarqué et
je me dis 13 régions éventuellement 13
taxe ou redevance 13 appareils embarqués
plus ce département comment comment tout
cela se gère
moi je suis assez d'accord pour qu'on
puisse laisser aux collectivités locales
la liberté ii de faire ou de ne pas
faire et je pense qu'à un moment donné
il faut centraliser que ce soit cohérent
parce que ça veut dire que les
entreprises par exemple vont recevoir 13
facture pour pour un passage d'un bout à
l'autre
patrice facture ce qu'ils feront pas
toutes les régions mais peut-être que si
quand même donc c'est la double peine
aussi pour les transporteurs français
qui paieront la tei cpe plein pot et qui
paieront cette taxe ou redevance
voilà moi je vais je vous les citer
l'exemple de l'île de france puisque la
présidente s'est déjà prononcée en 10
ans voit ça nous intéresse de mettre en
place cette redevance et elle sera
affectée à la transition énergétique
donc de voler dans la question donc le
volet national tu es ici p a fit ademe
et puis un volet affectation également
du produit de cette taxe ou redevance à
la transition dans les régions je vais
je vais donner la parole à en visio à
monsieur louis jean de nicolay merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
beaucoup de questions était déjà posée
moi j'aurais juste redire sur ce qu'a
dit mon collègue guillaume chevrollier
très justement sur les conventions de
desserte locale et notamment chose que
vous avez avancé d'une heure une
discussion avec la sncf en 2023 je pense
que si on veut que la voiture diminue au
profit du train dit ferroviaire il faut
qu'ils gravent véritablement un meilleur
accord entre les lignes et les ter
régionaux on arrive souvent à thébaux
minutes un train un tgv que par
conséquent les objets prendre sa voiture
pour faire vingt ou trente de plus on
trouvait une gare tgv complet donc je
crois qu'il ya un vrai travail de
coordination et j'espère que les
collectivités seront associés à cette
coordination entre la sncf et les télés
les trains régionaux que ça semble plus
efficace et pis je me permet aussi de
2,2 de vous rappeler que les spots et la
suppression des lignes aériennes entre
nantes bordeaux et autres on pourra
amener à la fois l'augmentation de ligne
lgv de trains sur les lignes tgv
supplémentaires
on espère que la sncf augmentera pas ses
tarifs puisqu'elle aura alors à un
monopole sur ses civils et ses lignes
par rapport à l'avion et que deuxième
aide que deuxièmement beaucoup de rêves
y arrivera
malgré le beau plan de relance mais ils
n'ont rien eu à temps des protections
phoniques plus importante surtout si le
trafic au mois je crois qu'à est un
véritable effort c'est pas tout à fait
le climat mais c'est la résilience de la
vie sur terre de la part des des
personnes aidées des riverains des
lignes lgv vous remercie mais merci
chers connaît c'est vrai que l'isolation
phonique c'est un sujet et que notre
collègue ramène souvent parce que il ya
des difficultés effectivement dans son
département aidé des bruits c'est
important du la ligne lgv et je revenais
sur la question des modèles y
effectivement sur le sur la mise en
place de ce super pour hugo contribution
l'appellera qu'on veut c'est vrai qu'il
ya des régions qui sont qui sont
peut-être candidate mais il y aura des
effets de bord pour les autres régions
et commence à tout ça va se dérouler
comme on va se mettre le dernier
intervenant madame avait merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais revenir sur ordonnance
permettant aux régions d'instituer des
construit bution sur la circulation des
véhicules de transport routier
si cette disposition semble attendu en
fait dans certaines régions comme
l'indiqué mon collègue tout à l'heure
elle ne l'est pas dans tout notamment la
mienne d'ailleurs les acteurs
économiques bretons nous font part de
leur inquiétude vis-à-vis de cette
disposition notre situation péninsulaire
si elle a parfois des avantages elle a
aussi parfois un handicap
je pense notamment au transport de
marchandises de secteurs comme
l'agroalimentaire souvent confrontés aux
fluctuations des cours et dont les
marges financières sont très très
étroite
je souhaite donc me faire le relais de
ma région et notamment de sa partie la
plus occidentale
à cela s'ajoute la suppression du
dispositif de remboursement partiel de
la tei cpe la réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre est une priorité
pour tous mais la puissance publique
doit accompagner structurellement ces
transitions aussi dans le prolongement
des discussions de ce texte au parlement
je serais favorable à un grand plan de
développement du fret ferroviaire pour
laquelle la bretagne de fait de sa
situation géographique pourrait servir
de nos territoires test pourriez vous
s'il vous plaît nous rappeler les
attention du gouvernement sur ce point
je vous remercie merci gbta dernière
intervenante non il y aura monsieur
jacques 1
[Musique]
merci président j'avais deux questions
mais intervenant à la fin je vais
pouvoir revenir sur un certain nombre de
questions qui vous ont été posées et
dont les réponses me semble insuffisante
en vue du passage dans l'hémicycle de ce
texte important celles de mon voisin
jacques fernique sur le vélo on imagine
qu'avec la révolution du vélo le vélo à
assistance électrique une augmentation
du fonds- vélos et des associations de
référence propose une augmentation de
300 millions d'euros à peu près alors
vous allez dire c'est beaucoup pour du
vélo ben je ne trouve pas ramené à
l'habitant ses 7 50 par an et par
habitant
ramenée à des travaux d'infrastructures
importantes par exemple le projet de
nouvelle gare tgv à nice c'est presque
ce montant là je suis pas contre le
projet de nouvelle gare à à nice
j'essaie de donner des ordres de
grandeur dans certains cas on n'hésite
pas et puis dans d'autres on hésite je
souhaite revenir aussi sur la première
question de mon président de commission
qui vous a clairement dit voilà la
stratégie fret et logistique va être
amené après le passage du texte
vous nous avez dit qu'il serait possible
en enverrait de prendre en compte
certaines de nos propositions
est-ce que vous pouvez être un peu plus
précis à cet endroit
et puis la question souhaitez-vous posée
était sur l'éco contribution alors je
trouve que l' ordonnance et j'en
remercie contexte de l'avoir diffusé le
projet d'ordonnancé je salue le fait
qu'elles viennent maintenant je tiens à
le dire à vos services un certain nombre
d'aspects assez intéressant lorsque le
texte a été voté au sénat nous avions
obtenu dans cette logique qui
prévalaient pour l'instituer sur l'a35
en alsace qu'il y ait un parallèle avec
l'autoroute a31 sur le sillon lorrain
ensuite à l'assemblée on nous l'a
un retour au quai donc je pense que
votre proposition permettrait de
satisfaire à cette exigence
mais j'ai une question technique
pourquoi l' ordonnance de l'écotaxe
alsace commence à partir de trois top-5
de tonnage là je pense qu'on aura des
effets périphériques sur les véhicules
utilitaires légers
ces petits véhicules qui circulent en en
surcharge
sans chrono tachygraphe sans contrainte
de temps du week-end et qui peuvent
traverser les villes et là j'ai vraiment
une question importante j'ai vu que vos
services avaient réussi à exonérer
d'écotaxe alsacienne un certain nombre
de professionnels qui feront du des
usages locaux des autoroutes je pense
qu'il y avait moyen de voir cette
question là et donc j'insiste sur les
questions composé mon collègue mandelli
sur cette écotaxe façon puzzle
appliqué au niveau national et la vue
d'ensemble qu'on n'a pas je n'imagine
pas autant je pouvais comprendre ce qui
s'est passé sur l'a35 et son extension à
la 31 autant ramené à toute la france à
l'initiative des régions on n'a pas de
vision d'ensemble et j'insiste aussi sur
la question de mon collègue sur la
question du verdissement des flottes
pour l'acceptabilité par les les
transporteurs d'une nouvelle et cotation
il faut absolument les accompagner sur
des changements de motorisation je pense
aux camions électriques qui ne sont pas
très pour tous les usages
mais pour les usages de courtes
distances au quotidien style 150 200 km
de cabotage à l'intérieur d'une région
il ya des solutions techniques qui
fonctionne il faut pouvoir les les
accompagner pima question que je
souhaitais vous pose est est en rapport
avec et gendrey fini président la
question de
un loupé je crois la loi d'orientation
des mobilités qui a eu la sagesse de
proposer qu'il n'y ait pas aux blanches
de mobilité en france est de couvrir le
pays d'autorité organisatrice de
mobilité j'ai signalé souligné qu'un
certain et nous l'avons fait au sénat
collectivement à l'unanimité car une
certain nombre de communautés de
communes ne disposait pas de bases de
taxe versement mobilité parce qu'elles
ont trop peu d'entreprises de plus de 11
personnes
nous avions à l'unanimité proposer un
dispositif qui permettait de recourir à
un taux réduit de versements mobilité
complétée par une dotation et ça ne
devrait pas être très coûteux parce que
ces territoires ne doivent pas être très
nombreux
j'ai par ailleurs suggéré qu'on
travaille sur la définition du transport
régulier qui permet de lever le
versement mobilité pour l'instant le
décret alors c'est du réglementaire ne
permet pas de lever le versement
mobilité si on fait du transport à la
demande
je vous ai donné l'exemple du
covoiturage courtes distances sur ligne
virtuelle dans quelle mesure nous
pourrions nous pas faire entrer ce genre
de disposition dans le décret pour
pouvoir lever le versement mobilité pour
des politiques de mobilité beaucoup
moins coûteuse que celle classique des
transports en commun urbains autour de
la définition actuelle du transport
régulier je vous remercie
merci cher collègue monsieur le ministre
chacun a toujours précisé monsieur le
président je vais essayer de répondre on
commence à entendre madame la sénatrice
fille elle pour peut-être citer de
chiffres d'abord dire que nous avons
très largement dans nos travaux essayer
de redonner une dynamique favorable et
positive au continuum portuaire
fluviales et maritimes de chiffres quand
on regarde ce continue à nous avons
investi sur le plan de relance seuls 400
millions d'euros donc sur le fluvial sur
le maritime et portuaire
mais j'ai signé il ya peut-être
maintenant dix jours la convention
décennale avec ou à navigables de france
pour 3 milliards sur 10 ans qui permet à
la fois de vrais sur les travaux de
régénération pour les grands gabarits
et puis d'apporter donc pour le fret et
d'apporter des réponses tout à fait
pertinente sur le trafic de plaisance en
lien avec les collectivités qui sont
considérés mais pour le dire on a le
même sujet sur le fluvial aujourd'hui
qu'on avait avec le ferroviaire avant le
plan petites lignes le sujet de la
vétusté des infrastructures et donc le
besoin d'avoir un travaux un travail et
d'être et des opérations de régénération
qui sont très importantes sur le sujet
des externalités dire que l'article 31
voter au modifié à l'assemblée prévoit
que les extraits des transports cuisse
et doivent être même compenser en
étudiant notamment les opportunités pour
le fluvial c'est un âge où je pense
qu'ils pourraient être utilement
peut-être encore enrichi dans votre
assemblée sur les différentes questions
de monsieur le sénateur mandji bon
d'abord être en accord avec ce que vous
avez dit sur le sujet de la sécurisation
des recettes de la fuite dans un moment
où nous allons continuer à avoir besoin
de recettes pour les infrastructures les
différents plans de rattrapage français
européens et internationaux dont
témoigne de l'actualité et du besoin
d'infrastructures publiques comme un
support tout à fait essentiel à cette
grande transformation économique et
industriel que que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure la philosophie actuelle du
gouvernement c'est de compenser la
baisse de l'avantagé fiscal actuel pour
le transport routier de marchandises et
de le compenser par un renforcement des
aides à la transition y compris
d'ailleurs pour les véhicules
industriels les plus lourds nous
parlions tout à l'heure de l'aide de
50000 euros par exemple sur sur les
camions électriques et je reviendrai
dans un instant le sujet à la fois du
fléchage de la télé cpe on connaît ce
débat est ici et ailleurs sur
l'affectation des taxes mais ce qui est
sûr c'est que 1 les besoins seront
importants et que deux la nature même de
la télé c'est peu si on raisonne un peu
moyen long terme ce sera mise en
question puisqu'elle est à 6 aujourd'hui
sur les produits énergétiques qu'ils
soient amenés à en volume diminue
beaucoup puisqu'on parle
relisez-vous tests que nous avons à 2040
2050 à la fois de la fin de la vente des
véhicules thermiques et de la diminution
drastique de ces deux séquences au
dessus de ces carburants notamment pour
les véhicules particuliers qui sont le
coeur le coeur du sujet sur les
questions de de monsieur le sénateur de
nicolet d'abord peut-être pour parler
rapidement des de la protection phonique
dl je vais dire que des travaux sont en
cours sur la lgv couper la loire
bretagne avec 11 millions d'euros qui
sont prévus et 5 millions d'euros qui
ont déjà été conventionnée pour les
premiers mur phonique et que les travaux
sont en cours avec la région en tout cas
les discussions sont en cours avec la
région de nouvelles aquitaine travaux
sont programmés le sang en attente du
retour du retour de la région sur le
sujet de l'articulation lgv ter
quatre tgv ter nous avons souvent ces
demandes nous allons essayer autant que
faire se peut de fluidifier les échanges
entre la sncf et les territoires et
notamment les régions et souvent cela
prospère convenablement sur le sujet de
global enfin plus globale est
intéressant et même essentiel de
l'attractivité de la transparence
tarifaire un exemple nous avons
évidemment demander à la sncf
d'accompagner cette reprise ou ce
nouveau déconfinement pendant l'été la
sncf a consenti de m même a pris une
initiative plutôt pour être pour leur
rendre hommage de d'avoir une politique
d'attractivité taillefer pour l'été tout
à fait tout à fait dynamique 5 millions
de billets à -39 europe et une politique
d'incitation pour les jeunes avec les
jeunes de moins de 12 ans qui pourront
bénéficier de billets à 8 euros tout
l'été et puis des package ou des offres
groupées avec le ter qui vont permettre
d'accompagner ce mouvement est donc de
l'attractivité tarifaire
ceci et doit être couplée avec la
politique de transparence tarifaire que
j'ai demandé à la sncf à la fois pour
donner de la visibilité aux clients et
pour pour éventuellement le cas échéant
c'est dur de respect ce masque le cas
échéant de pouvoir reparler des sujets
importants notamment de des baisses de
la tva mais qui aujourd'hui je le dis de
façon très très sincère ne trouverez pas
d'efficacité dès lors qu'on n'a pas des
mécanismes de transparence tarifaire
efficace pour répondre aux 55 questions
de monsieur sénateur jacques a d'abord
dire que sur le plan vélo
nous avions et je le disais a mis en
place à un implant vélo de 350 millions
d'euros enrichi au moment du plan de
relance de 200 millions d'euros c'était
zéro avant avant 2017 et ça nous a
d'ores et déjà permis de financer de
sécuriser le financement pour 11 me km
de pistes dans un mouvement qui ne se
dément pas et qui est qui va croissant
là aussi la france est en train de
résorber son retard sur le sujet sur les
questions de fret et de logistique et de
l'apport du sénat
le joli vraiment sans malice vous avez
été d'une aide précieuse sur
les sujets portuaire dame a porté par
votre ancien collègue monsieur monsieur
basse par donc moi je j'aborderai dans
un esprit ouvert les discussions que
nous aurons nous aurons en séance pour
voir s'il ya matière à trouver à trouver
convergence sous les sujets de
l'accompagnement plus précisément sur
l'offre notamment des poids-lourds et
l'offre électrique
nous avons donc mis en place ce cette
aide à la transition de 50000 euros
je le dis de façon tout à fait sincère
là aussi cette aide elle a été peu
demandés pour l'instant parce que sur
coup dans le moment que nous connaissons
est important et nous aurons très
certainement à renforcer en tout cas moi
je le souhaite ces aides à la conversion
je prends un exemple aujourd'hui le
surcoût il est quasiment de 200000 euros
pour l'acquisition d'un camion
électrique l'allemagne effet cent mille
euros des de la californie 150000 euros
dead
donc tout ça évidemment l'effort a porté
sur le plan financier est très très fort
au départ mais dès lors qu'on massifie
la production on arrive à baisser les
coûts et l'idée c'est quand même que
nous puissions sur ses offres bénéficier
d'une offre française et européenne qui
soit qu'ils soient majoritaires nos
petits soit doit s'accompagner ou où se
se compléter de façon harmonieuse et
enfin sur les sujets de fiscalité et
notamment les les sujets de versements
mobilité et de compléments moi je serai
à avoir cette discussion j'imagine qu'en
loi de finances nous aurons aussi à en
débattre
mais ça renvoie à la question de
monsieur le sénateur mode et lit tout à
l'heure et enfin sur le sujet du ciblage
des 305 bon là d'abord l'idée c'était
normativement réglementairement de
cibler les polo qui commence à être au
top 5 c'était une demande particulière
de la collectivité européenne d'alsace
de ne cibler que les poids lourds
d'où la référence explicite à à ce
chiffre de 35 et le tout sera précisée
évidemment
ça leur donne ans voilà monsieur le
président en substance ce que je pouvais
vous dire aujourd'hui
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
localités de cette audition merci à mes
collègues pour l'intérêt de leurs
questions et vous voyez que le que le
débat est largement ouvert et que
beaucoup de points restent en
interrogation mais que notre assemblée
ne manquera pas de faire un certain
nombre et de grandes propositions dans
le cadre du débat que nous serons amenés
à mettre en place à partir du 14 juin
prochain merci monsieur ministre et une
bonne soirée
[Musique]